this is a production of Cornell
University connection and thank you all
for coming it's really ok you hear me
yeah ok it's really great to to see all
of you here and I'm very excited to
present my research on route and
rhizosphere processes in forest soils
today I'm actually not the first Dutch
person to observe routes or study routes
all right so FinCEN franco was way ahead
of me he observed and painted tree roots
and the reason for him that he got so
interested in roots is was because to
him tree roots represented the struggle
of life well he wasn't the most
optimistic person and I would not use
roots as a metaphor of my own life or
even my own PhD but I would argue that
roots can really be a struggle to study
there they're hidden away in the soil
they're hard to get to and it's hard to
like observe them under natural
conditions but once you find methods or
you use all their methods to to study
them and learn new things about them
they are truly fascinating and on top of
that they play a very important role in
the cycling of carbon and nutrients
through our environments so I would
argue that they're definitely studying
them is definitely worth the struggle
and I hope you you agree with me so the
roots dead then go painted here are more
woody structural roots and those are not
the roadstead that I was interested in
for my dissertation there is I was
interested in our fine roots so those
are really smallest roots of their roots
it's them we're talking really about the
millimeter scale here and these these
roots are also ephemeral meaning that
after a certain period of time they're
shed just like leaves on a tree but
unlike leaves on the tree their
production season and their death season
so to say are variable and their
lifespan can really vary from a few days
up to a few years this is also a part of
the root system that's in charge of
taking up water and nutrient
from the soil their de roots that
associated with beneficial
microorganisms in the soil and they're
also the part of the root system that
can quickly respond to changes in the
environments and they can do that by
producing roots in more roots in an area
of the soil where there's higher
nutrient availability or resource
availability but they can also do this
by changing their lifespan and besides
responding to the environment they also
have the ability to modify the soil
right around right around these roots so
the biological characteristics the
physical characteristics and the
chemical characteristics around the
roots in the soil are are very different
from from the rest of the soil and one
of the reason of the reasons for this is
root exudates it isn't the process by
which roots release chemicals into the
soil and I will talk more about this
about this in a bit at the ecosystem
scale fine roots growth dynamics are
very important part of the carbon cycle
in fact more than orange of organic
carbon found on land and is stored in
forests and a big part of that pool is
found below grounds as there in the
context of climate change one of the big
questions is what is going to happen
with this huge pool of carbon stored in
forests and one of the reasons that we
that we don't we aren't able to answer
that question yet is because we have a
very limited understanding of root soil
interactions and how and about how
changes in the environments might may
change those interactions so the aim of
my dissertation was to enhance our
understanding of root soil interactions
in a changing climate and I did this by
studying two different components within
this system so the first part of my
dissertation is about the effect of
droughts on fine grid production and
lifespan and then the second part of my
presentation or my dissertation is about
the effective route oxidation on soil
organic matter dynamics and so this is
also the way that I will guide you from
my talk today
right so the first part of my
dissertation the effects of drought on
on fine roots actually took place in
Germany in collaboration with the
Technical University of Munich and I was
lucky enough to be able to take
advantage of this through fall exclusion
infrastructure that has been installed
in one of the forest nearby to study the
response of fine roots to drought at the
field scale and studying route responses
to water resources in the soil is
particularly tricky because we expect
drought to affect find reproduction in
different ways so first of all water
resources are going to be more limiting
in the soil and so usually when we think
of a plant growing in in an environment
with limiting soil resources the
expectation is that the plant would
induce more biomass and more carbon
below grounds to to forage for those
resources and really spend its energy on
finding those resources in the soil and
taking them up however in the in the
scenario of a drought drought is also
going to influence above-ground
physiology of the tree and so one of the
main strategies by which trees can
minimize water loss is through closing
the stomata in the leaf leaves but that
also means that less co2 can be taken
out and so then we get into a scenario
where maybe the tree is limited in
Carmen resources and therefore also has
limited resources to spend on root
production so this was considered
there's really these two different
effects that that take place and it's
hard to predict because of that what
what would happen to find root growth
dynamics the low grounds and so studying
the effect of droughts in temperate
forest ecosystems is important because
the the duration the frequency and
severity of drought is predicted to go
up even in areas where trees are usually
not water limited an additional reason
for for
stirrers and this is I was working or
collaborating with force there's at the
Technical University of Munich is that
one of their most economically important
trees is Norway spruce and is this tree
species is particularly vulnerable to
drought and this might be partly due to
a shallow root system so all these roots
are in the layer of the soil that is
gonna dry out the fastest and these
trees are mainly grown in monoculture so
initial question is like why what can
what kind of management strategies could
we find to to mitigate these negative
effects of droughts on the root system
of very spruce so with this background
in mind I tested two hypotheses in this
study the first one being that drought
reduces fine reproductions but will
increase root lifespan and the rationale
behind this was is that the tree will
have limited carbon resources to to
build more roots but to compensate for
that the fine roots that are already
there are going to live for longer my
second hypothesis was that mixed species
arrangements will buffer the negative
effects of drought on fine reproduction
and to to further explain why why I
think that's gonna happen I have a
little diagram here so you can imagine a
forest a monoculture forest of spruce
trees on the on the left and so there's
gonna be a lot of fine roots in that
upper layer of the soil and they're
going to be competing for those limited
resources that are already there well if
you have a forest where there's forest
over there spruce trees and beech trees
that's the other species that I studied
here there's going to be fewer the the
the distribution of roots will be more
even and so also resources can be shared
more efficiently and more equally more
evenly and in addition because beech has
a deeper root system there might be
other mechanisms by which beech can
facilitate the fine reproduction of
spruce for example by by hydraulic lift
the way that I tested these hypothesis
was through a four year long field study
at the site which I already showed a
picture and
is this field side had ten research
plots and that's had a species gradient
so she can seem to Graham in the middle
of the blood you see a mixed zone of
both beech and spruce trees and then on
the side monocultures of beech or spruce
and then half of these plots at full
through full extinction rooms were
installed on top of them and so these
roofs would close if it was raining but
then also during the winter months they
were also left open so really the idea
was here to study the effect of seasonal
like summer droughts or a drought during
the growing season on hybrid production
but we still let some soil moisture be
recharged during during the winter
months and the way that I I observed the
fine roads was by using mini raisa tron
methods so you can see a tube here and
that well the outside of the tube here
but it goes down to 50 centimeters and
the tube is see-through and so then with
cameras we can monitor if any new fine
roots are produced or how old the fine
roots are that that are already there
and so but we had to really come back
every two weeks to keep on monitoring
these roots and I want to thank
undergraduate researchers from the
Technical University of Munich for this
because they were really the one that
this most of the time and so we had 60
tubes and totals with six tubes per plot
and then we would come back there were
44 pictures per tube and then we would
come back every two weeks for almost to
eat for almost four years so we had a
lot of a lot of Route pictures to do
with and different members of them
barley lab helped me with analyzing all
these pictures I was I see Tommy sitting
here today and well there's a there's a
whole big group and Max even our lab
technician helps I want to also thank
all of you for all your help there
because I really couldn't have gotten
through all those pictures by myself we
also had soil moisture sensors installed
intuitive plots so that we could double
check that these through full exclusion
roofs are actually doing their job and
this is a graph where we see soil
moisture into upper 10 centimeters of
the soils we also had sensors installed
deeper down into the soil and this is
soil moisture all over the years of the
study and then they're also marked when
their roofs were closed versus when they
were open and so the thing that I want
you to take away from this graph is that
we have three red lines which represent
the drought treatment and three blue
lines and then there were soil moisture
sensors in the beach sprues and mixtone
but what I want to take away from is is
that the drought treatment is working so
we get reduced soil moisture when their
roofs are closed but also we can see
that even when the roofs are open soil
moisture isn't fully recharged all right
so the the first results that I'm
sharing with you are on the total amount
of fine words that were produced during
the four years of this study and so we
have I'm showing here pine root
production of beech and spruce and then
in the control plotting the drought
floods and so you can see deads drought
indeed significantly affected fine wood
production of spruce and and slightly of
beech so that's in line with our
hypothesis that we thought that drought
was gonna reduce fine reproduction and
then if we if we look at the mixed zone
of the plot so this is the total find
root production of both beech and spruce
together we do not see a reduction in
fine root production so that's also in
line with what I hypothesized then we
can also look at fine root production by
depth so here I'm showing you fine bird
production of spruce in beach in the
Indus Engle species zone of the plots as
there we see that fiber production is
reduced in the upper layers but also in
the deeper layers of the soil so even
though in the deeper layers of the soil
soil moisture was higher
we still see this reduction which
suggests that the trees indeed may have
been carbon limited so just couldn't
Purdue
as many words as they as they might have
on there under more ideal conditions
then if we look at the mixed species
zone we do not see this effect on earth
drought on this find reproduction of
spruce so and none of the layers we see
a reduction in find reproduction
well beech still shows a decrease in
fine reproduction from 10 to 20
centimeters soil depth and so we can
kind of average their results here over
those depth layers to kind of summarize
the results that we see in the mix
versus the singles species floods and so
we see that beach is equally affected by
the droughts in in the single and mixed
species own while spruce is only
affected by the drought in the spangles
treaty zone but not in the next species
own and so card part of this result
first fruits might be explained by
looking at the differences in soil
moisture between the singles species
zone of spruce and the mixed species
zone so if you look at the soil water
content in the drought plots of the
mixed species and spruce zone we see
that the soil moisture in the mixed
species zone is significantly higher
than in the single species zone so that
may explain part of why we see that
spruce is less affected by the drought
in the mixed zone to an estimate a fine
word lifespans of the routes that I was
observing I used Cox proportional
hazards models and a kaplan-meier
estimates and what we found for medium
lifespan is that both for screws and
Beach droughts increased fine with
lifespan in both the mix and the single
species zone so that's also in line with
if what what I have prophesized however
if we then look over these when we look
at this over the years and so a
different way to look at
medium lifespan or something that is
related to fine root lifespan is looking
at the hazard ratio so you can look at
the risk of death in the drought versus
the control plot and so hazard ratio
less than 1 in this case means that
there's a higher that there's a lower
risk of mortality in the drought floods
well a hazard ratio that is higher than
1 means a higher higher risk in the
drought floods so you can see for spruce
here that's throughout the years it's
hazard ratio is below 1 and the first
three years it's also it's significant
so it seems like it's response is quite
steady in a way however for beech we
only see a reduced risk of mortality
which would be linked to a longer
lifespan in in the first year of the
study and then for the next few years
it's that changes so this suggests that
maybe for beech this isn't a sustained
strategy under repeated episodes of
summer drought or maybe it's it's it's
utilizing other strategies to to deal
with this reduced soil moisture in the
soil moisture soil
so for all what do these what do these
results mean for for carbon cycling in
poor as well if we have less fine bird
production and the fine roots that are
already there are are getting older that
means that there is less there's going
to be less fine return over and the rate
and amount at which carbon would be
transferred into would be transferred to
a soil organic matter pool is is gonna
decrease however it seems that if we
look at mixed species arrangements or
mixed species for us that this negative
effect of drought may be mitigated to a
certain extent and especially because
spruce is the one that is benefiting
from from this mixed species composition
it seems like this could be a better
forest management strategy if foresters
want to cultivate Norway spruce
they're in a climate where maybe more
drought periods are to be expected all
right that brings me to the second part
of my dissertation in this second part I
I studied the effect of root exudates
chemistry on on soil carbon cycling my
interest in soil science and our new I
did my Master's like Tarun already said
in soil science with Johannes but really
my interest in soil go even further back
than that this is me as a child
practicing my soil sampling skills and
for everyone that has asked me over the
years if we wear clogs or wooden shoes
in the Netherlands we do and this is the
proof for that
so yeah I'm practicing my soil sampling
skills and I look a little confused
there's no organic matter in the soil
and there's there's no roots so what's
going on cuz we need this area where
roots and the soil meet is is an area
disorder that I find very interesting
and this interface is is also called
their Rice's sphere and this is really
two plays very roots interact with with
a diverse community of organisms of
microorganisms in vertebrates other
plant species and lately this region of
the soil has also been labeled as a
hotspot of biological activity meaning
that we can observe accelerated rates of
carbon and nutrient cycling in this
soils in this zone and a recent study
showed that these rhizosphere processes
may be responsible for up to one third
of all soil carbon mineralized in
forests and so this dis phenomenon is
also called root priming and so and one
of the main there's people have proposed
different mechanisms for why this is
happening but one of the main
mechanisms attributes this effect to
root x addition so it is that this idea
of roots releasing chemicals into the
soil that then results in an increase or
decrease in organic matter decomposition
and so just to explain this hypothesis
that's out there in a little bit more
detail we can start with imagining a
soil without any roots and I show
there's a fix or carbon pool and we have
some microbes living in that soil that
are chewing away on this soil organic
matter and some of the carbon is leaving
the system as a co2 and then what what
has been commonly hypothesized is what
happens when we introduce roots into the
system is that roots are exuding label
carbon compounds organic compounds that
are easy to break down that then either
increase the activity of the microbes
that live there or even the abundance of
there microbes which then results in
them also decomposing more of this
carbon soil organic matter pool which
then results overall in a in a larger
flux of co2 leaving the system and of
course some of this co2 is coming from
the exit days that were that are
degraded and some of that is coming from
the soil however my question it was when
I when I read about this is this is this
really true is this really true for all
exudates that are being excluded because
really so their roots exudes a very wide
variety of chemicals and really the
majority of those chemicals we haven't
even identified yet so that's that's
where we start we don't even know the
variety of chemicals that that is being
exerted and then we also don't know what
these they're how these different
chemicals would affect the soil
microbial community so we don't know
that either
and then really we also don't really
know what what would happen if we see no
change at all an increase or decrease in
soil organic matter decomposition and if
you if you read Studies on word priming
that have been done with different plant
species you indeed buy
that sometimes slow microbial
respiration is increased sometimes it's
decreased sometimes there's no effect at
all so we're missing out on a full
explanation of the mechanisms that's
play a role in this root priming
phenomena and so one of the reasons why
I think is just hypothesis that I just
explained or just food resource
hypothesis of label label compounds got
so much support is because when he's
experiment when they're experiments were
designed to study this phenomenon in the
lab and mostly glucose was used as a
proxy for route excitation so it is very
like simple simple soil incubations
where either artificial roots were
created as you can like as an example I
give you on the slide or just compounds
were added by pipetting them into the
soil and then the effect of glucose on
so carbon cycling which measured
however like I've already been
emphasizing roots exude a lot of
different compounds and one really large
group of compounds that has been largely
ignored in these crude priming studies
are secondary metabolites and so
secondary metabolites are expected to
show a higher variation across species
but also the group of compounds that I
thought was important to study have been
studying in soils and has been shown to
to have different functions so not just
a food source but they can in certain
cases be toxic it can decrease enzyme
activities or inhibit enzyme activities
and they play a role in plant microbe
signaling and they can mobilize other
resources that might have been
immobilized in the soil so there's
there's a lot of other functions that
could be or a lot of other mechanisms
that could be playing a role here so I
designed two experiments to really test
one hypothesis which was that root
phenolic compounds to has function as a
microbial food source but influence so
carbon cycling through other mechanisms
and so the first experiment that I
designed started with identifying the
exudates of six different tree species
because if I didn't even know which
phenolic compounds were exuded and how
could I test their effect on on
rhizosphere biogeochemistry and so I a
grew tree species in the greenhouse on
their in us in a medium that didn't
contain any organic matter and then I
transferred them to hydroponics and
eventually that I measured their
exudates by putting them in individual
jars and with cellulose acetate strips I
sampled the phenolic from that solution
and for this part of my experiment I
want to thank Andre Kessler with whom I
collaborated a lot and I wasn't it was a
struggle in the beginning to find a
method that was working to work with
these fanatics and I'd also like to
thank the rest of his lab for helping
with HPLC analysis so then after after I
identified these compounds the next step
was to to test a subset of these on on
soil microbial respiration so I'd have
my control soil and then similar to what
other incubation studies that we're
looking at root priming or priming have
done I added different phenolic
compounds to the soil and then measured
so microbial respiration using potassium
hydroxide traps yeah so
measuring read exudate I would say this
was really struggle of my PhD it's it's
very challenging to measure them you
you're working with very small
concentrations and I actually started
with try I got my first idea was to
measure root X addition even in the
forests in Germany then I brought it to
a smaller scale outside I'm still
growing the roots in a potted medium and
try to excavate parts of the root system
and like put them in tubes and try to
catch through exudate but none of this
none of this was working and that's how
in the end I ended up in the greenhouse
with a hydroponic system but as you can
see I Luca I look quite happy so it
worked out in here so yeah so with this
with this method I identified 181 unique
root exudates that belong to nine
different bio synthetic classes and but
out of these 181 exudates I only found
five matches with standards that I use
so it just demonstrates their lead a big
diversity of chemicals that we haven't
identified yet however I was able to for
most chemicals put them into a bio
synthetic or a sign a bio synthetic
class to them so we did have some extra
information and then I I wanted to
answer this question of how unique the
these phenolic profiles were were among
species so how species specific they
were so I used an NM d s analysis for
that and so the way that you can
interpret this flood is that points that
are closer together are more similar and
points data points that are further
apart are are more dissimilar and so I
tested six different tree species here
and as you can see a cluster quite
tightly together meaning that this
phenolic profiles were very unique to
that species however we also see some
overlap in the case of oak and beech
and so then out of those other I try to
test a subset of these phenolic
compounds and tested their effect on
soil microbial respiration and I try to
choose compounds that belong to the
different chemical classes that I had
identified and so here you see those
chemicals on the x-axis and then the
amount of co2 that was respired over
five-day periods and I included glucose
as a positive control and then you see
the control that didn't receive any
phenolic addition in the middle in dark
blue and so what I want you to take away
from this graph is dead you can see that
phenolic compounds can both increase
decrease or have no effect on soil
microbial respiration so this goes
already against these most common
hypotheses common hypothesis or common
mechanism that has been proposed to
explain root priming then an additional
thing that that I found was very
interesting when looking at these result
is that it seems that the biosynthetic
class that the compound belongs to is
not determining whether this compound is
going to have a negative a positive or
no effect on respiration as you can see
there's three flavonoid compounds in
this graph and there they can narrow in
Jenin is increasing respiration or
saxophone and and cadogan are decreasing
respiration and then additionally if you
look at the compounds that suppress
respiration so those are the ones in red
they did they all share the same
functional group category and so this
supports the hypothesis that made a
functional group of the compounds is
more important in determining the
compounds effect on soil microbial
respiration than the biosynthetic class
and so for my next study I want you to
remember these three compounds so
benzoic acid that's increased
respiration and then caffeic acid and
catechin that decreased respiration
because I will I I'm gonna further study
them in my next experiment
so for all from from this first
experiment I can conclude that roots
exude a large variety of phenolic
compound and that these phenolic
profiles are quite unique to one species
and that these compounds can result in a
variety of effects on soil microbial
respiration however they're also still a
lot of unknowns are some unknowns that I
was specifically interested in and the
first was well okay so we have this
total flux of co2 coming from the system
but what part of this flux is coming or
what which part of this carbon is coming
from the exudate or which carbon which
part of the carbon came from from the
soil
then also I still don't know really how
these microbials responded to to the
exudates that were added and so what the
mechanism really was by which they
degraded more or less soil carbon and
then lastly and this is this is just in
general a problem with with studying the
effect of root exudates in the way that
I did and that other studies did is that
we're always just adding one compounds
to the soil well roots exudes so many
compounds at the same time so whether
the individual fact of one root exudate
is gonna be the same when there's a
bunch of compounds added it's also still
an open question so for this second
experiment I I collaborated with a lot
of people to answer these these
remaining questions and I first want to
thank Quanah munos okis if it hadn't
been for her I would have included a
sequencing component into this study so
thank you for all your help and support
and I also want to thank jet sparks
which helped me a lot with figuring out
the methods to measure to use stable
isotope analysis to distinguish between
the soil and exudate source of carbon
and I also want to thank Kim sparks and
just coil in general then I also want to
thank guy awakens' who helped me with
the design of the experiment enzyme
analysis microbial biomass I also want
to thank his graduate student Natalie
Bray because she was the
who teach me or showed me how to use
them COC machine so thanks a lot for
that and then lastly I want to thank
Rollie who Roland will him from the
Bucky lab who helped further supported
me in Kelowna with the sequencing part
of the study all right so this soil
exudate incubation was similar to the
incubation that I did in the previous
study only did this incubation took
longer so I was 38 days in total and
then I used 13c labeled compound so that
I was able to distinguish between carbon
coming from soil and carbon coming from
the exudates
and I used two different methods to
measure soil respiration I still use my
koh or Koh traps to get an estimate of
the total amount or cumulative amount
carbon respired over the course of the
experiment but I also on several days
from day one day to day five day 15 and
the last day of the experiment
I also took to our interval gas samples
and then through using healing plots I
could estimate the Delta 13c signature
of the source of carbon being respired
and then also to get more this microbial
mechanism that was that was could maybe
explain part of these patterns that we
were seeing I stick with destructive
samples on day 5 day 15 and at the end
for the enzyme analysis for microbial
biomass microbial abundance and and also
for sequencing part or to cook microbial
community analysis of the study I and
then a last thing that that I want to
mention about or that was different from
the last study is that I introduced
glucose into the story and I chose
glucose because that's the compound that
has been mowed wisely study and I wanted
to see if its effect would be the same
when a compound and phenolic compound
was added at the same time that already
showed has these different effects and
so microbial respiration and so I had
treatments where I added just a phenolic
and the glucose or I added the phenolic
and glucose together and in the cases
where there was just a single compound
dose were so different no leak was
labeled or the glucose was labeled but
indicates very added
compounds the glucose was labeled so I
couldn't I didn't have a way well so I
could distinguish between the carbon
coming from the glucose and from there
from there look at the soil together I
did estimate the amount of carbon that
came from the soil by subtracting the
amount of phenolic compound degraded in
the individual treatments all right so
here are the chemicals that I already
introduced from our previous study so I
tested the effect of benzoic acid
caffeic acid and cadogan at a high and a
low dose then glucose and so then I
ended up with 14 treatments in total and
then with destructive samples that I was
taking at these different time points I
ended up with a lot of charts in a
growth chamber gurmann and so yeah a lot
of jars and also a lot of results so
that's a good thing but for the sake of
this talk I'm going to focus on these
three points that I already mentioned
that I was interested in learning more
about and if you want to learn even more
about it then maybe tomorrow all right
so this first question of where where to
what extent are these root exudates
actually degraded and so I'm showing you
a graph here of the degradation of the
individual treatments and individual
compounds over the first 15 days of the
experiment and so you can see first
let's look at glucose so that's the
black line and so you can see that on
day one it's it's almost it's it's the
greatest to the highest degree and then
it already Crary quickly drops and by
day 15 it's it's similar to the it's not
being degraded much anymore and and then
for benzoic acid we do see some
degradation it's just a little slower
but this just goes this goes against my
hypothesis that these phenolic aren't
rated at all so they are utilized but
then if you look at caffeic acid and
Cadogan they are almost not degraded or
not degraded and so that is in line with
what I with what I have both says then
if we look at the amount of carbon that
is respired from the soil so this is
over 238 days of the experiments we see
that only so the control here is in grey
and we see that only glucose increases
decomposition so organic matter
decomposition and benzoic acid at the
high dose and so because I only picked
up on this effect for or a difference in
soil organic matter decomposition for
benzoic acid and glucose I'm going to
show you a graph of just those two
treatments so this is the same as what I
showed you in the previous graph but
then what I was interested in is this
interactive effect of benzoic acid and
glucose on the breakdown carbon and so
what we see is that when they're added
together the amount of so organic matter
that is decomposed is decreased as
increased and this is actually more than
if you would just add the their effects
of the individual treatments and we can
use enzyme analysis to get a better idea
of what kind of carbon sources were
degraded and so I found no difference in
phenol oxidase or peroxidase activity
but I did find a big increase in in
embedded glucose today's activity in the
benzoic acid treatments and in the Bozo
benzoic acid and glucose treatments it
suggests that the carbon sources that
were utilized were on the more label
side and not very complex or aromatic
and so then
then my girl Buell mechanisms that I was
interested in studying I just wanted to
quickly elaborate on that before moving
into the results so the question that I
was interested in is to what extent a
change in microbial respiration is
linked to an increase or decrease in
microbial abundance or microbial
community or both so you can imagine
your control we're know from the only
compound is edit and then if you do add
a phenolic compounds but we don't see
and a change in abundance and we don't
see a change in the community then maybe
the mechanism involved is triggering
mechanism so the metabolism of the
microbes that are living in that soil is
triggered and that's the reason why we
see in this case I'm using an increase
in in respiration as my example but you
could argue it's you could argue the
same thing for a decrease in respiration
or if we don't see a change in the
community but we do see a change in
abundance
then maybe it's this increase in
microbial biomass that's that is linked
with this increase in respiration or if
we don't see a craze in abundance but we
do see an increase in a do see a shift
in the community then maybe it's this
change the community that is linked to
to a change in respiration so community
that is may be more actively degrading
carbon resources or even maybe a
community that it consists of more
degraders
soy organic carbons so start miss
showing you a graph of microbial
abundance as affected by the different
phenolic treatments and so we have
benzoic acid caffeic acid and catechin
and the control and we see that even
though benzoic acid increased microbial
respiration overall and it's its
abundance is not increased and then if
we
caffeic acid in Cadogan and we do see a
decrease in abundance and these
treatments were also the one that we're
showing more of a decrease in
respiration so maybe in this case
abundance could explain part of this
story but not in the case of benzoic
acid and so here are my microbial
community results and so this is similar
plot that I showed as to the one with
the root exudates variation among three
species so again like points that are
closer together are more similar and
then points that are further apart or
more are more difference and well the
first thing that so these are samples
taking a day by day 0-5 1538 so the
first thing that stand out is that the
microbial community changed over time
cuz we see this you see this shift with
the days our days are grouped together
but then the thing that that I was more
interested in seeing is what these
phenolic compounds were doing to the
community and so you can see the benzoic
acid so those are the data points in
blue are very far shifted away from the
control that is in gray though if you
look at glucose which is in black it's
very closely grouped together to this
control especially on on day five so
this suggests that even though glucose
and benzoic acid were both increasing
respiration that may be the mechanism by
which it did this was different
and so furred so overall like these two
graphs it's I've already tested the
effect of phenolic compounds on
abundance and on the microbial community
but we can further test this by using
Spearman correlations and the the unit
that I used here for the shift in
microbial community is that I calculated
the distance from these individual data
points to the control so that is kind of
my measure for the shift income in the
community that took place and so then we
find
if you look at a graph a dead there was
a significant correlation between the
shift in the community and the change in
microbial respiration well if we look at
the second graph graph bead and we do
not see a correlation between microbial
abundance and microbial respiration and
so then the next question was okay so we
see a shift in the community but what is
really changing or who is changing and
we found that in the benzoic acid
treatment the Burkholder Ian parable
called the Rhea general which
ecologically are kind of still treated
as the same genus even though
phylogenetically they have been
separated recently the day were the ones
that showed the greatest increase in in
abundance under the under the benzoic
acid treatment and this these genera are
known to be prevalent in forest soils
which was the soil that i used for both
incubation studies and they're also
known to be able to the great phenolic
s' quite efficiently and also be able to
tolerate their toxicity and at the same
time they also play a role in soil
organic matter decomposition so then we
can start seeing that this mechanism
that maybe with the addition of benzoic
acid we selected for micro microbial
genera that it could tolerate that could
degrade these compounds that could color
aids potential toxicity but that were
also quite efficient at breaking down as
organic matter so even though benzoic
acid also was used as a food source and
also increased respiration I think that
that the mechanism by which it was done
was different maybe it caused a change
in the microbial community and that was
what was more linked to this change in
respiration so then to bring it back to
my overall hypothesis that I was testing
in these two experiments so is it our
phenolic is used as a microbial food
source well yes in the case of benzoic
acid no in the case of of Cadogan and
caffeic acid or to a lesser degree but
the mechanism by which this food source
was in the end causing also a change in
organic matter decomposition was
different it was it was changing the
community and so other phenolic
mechanisms that may be I that I found
some evidence for were toxicity in the
case of acid in cadogan's we saw this
decrease in the in abundance and there
there's other mechanisms that I did that
my results don't exclude but that we
would need further evidence for to to to
support them so that brings me to the
end of my talk so I shared my results
today one about the responses of fine
roots to droughts and then secondly the
mechanisms by which root exudates can
influence organic matter decomposition
and so I answered some questions but
there's still a lot of remaining
questions it's a very complex system to
study but I hope that you agree with me
that answering these remaining questions
is is worth the struggle and so with
that I want to thank many people first
of all my major adviser Darren barley
thanks so much for all your support
I've really yeah pretty enjoyed working
with you and very much appreciated the
freedom and confidence and tools you
gave me to develop my dissertation
project so thanks so much that I'd also
like to thank the rest of my committee
team Andre Jed and Kyle it's been really
a pleasure to work with all of you and
yeah I've learned a lot from you and I'm
very grateful for discussing my results
with you and manuscript revisions help
with research methods so thank you so
much um okay I'm just gonna keep them
going I would like to thank all the
members of the bar early laughs Quanah
was also a collaborator and Annika and
for the undergraduates that helped me
last animations as well also like to
thank my other collaborators mark kobold
Orson grams and Fritz that were involved
in the Germany study and enrollee then
also Cornell's just great for it's so
many facilities and the technical help
and support that analytical support I've
received has just been amazing everyone
there and uh just wider sips community
Johannes my master's advisors and
surgeon who i t-84 for many years and
Soho and a horticulture staff and also
my funding sources and lastly my family
and friends have been yeah just
wonderful and I really don't know how I
would have done it without all of you
especially my friends here in Ithaca and
my boyfriend's who is now with me and
friends so yeah resource use efficiency
compliment yeah I guess you didn't
measure know if you have some
measurements that really did the
complementarity did not decrease you to
obtaining and did indeed also increase
growth above ground
yes so other collaborators that were
that are part of this study are
measuring the above-ground above-ground
parameters and well we found that
drought is decreasing in carbon uptake
and in terms of the complementary part
they haven't found well they haven't
published their results yet and their
results aren't super convincing but
there are some in there are some
increases or increases it seems like it
is the effect of drought is slightly
mitigated but it isn't super convincing
yeah and they have there there's other
part of the study is that there is this
so there's this one big controlled
fruitful exclusion site and then there's
also a larger gradient of precipitation
gradient where they're looking at smell
mainly above ground parameters as well
and in some of these studies they have
found this complimentary effects above
ground but not at the Crown's Burgh
sites where I was working
yeah I think so yeah due to these mixed
systems yeah maybe I guess let's hope
they find that find anything mixtures
peach mixture studies yeah Devon those
have those long consistent mixture of X
and not not completely not completely
consistent but there are studies that
show that there is a complementary
effect and that there is greater growth
yeah so this was a few meters so like
maybe 2 3 meters yeah
or how entry modifiers anatomically
those five routes
hmm no no I don't know I don't I don't
know yeah that's I guess I can old as I
can say they try to maintain the route
for a longer but because it's like it's
kind of this question of are you gonna
are you gonna use are you gonna shed
your route or are you just are you going
to maintain it for longer and just keep
on sending resources its way but if
there is something anatomically that
changes so that you have like a super
route that can leave a little longer I
don't know genetics results on carbon
pollution yeah so alex has a result in
terms of the lifespan harder yeah so he
he found the relationship between
lifespan and respiration so that I think
the breeze was longer lifespan had lower
respiration rates yeah so alright this
has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu